it's a sound bite with Jake Paul talking
about oh we're gonna start a fight
leaders or a uh you know a union I've
heard that it stops there man that's it
that's all it happens hey whatever
happened with that and it hits a huge
you know sound bite but no one ever
follows through like we actually now
it's no longer a sound bite like our
Fighters have health insurance yeah like
it's not we're going to so we have we
did I think that's a way to make a
splash that's for sure in this sport
because you know Frank's been doing it
long and I have but we've both been
around the block where this isn't
something I even thought of where
Fighters get health insurance or
something like that